[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: One of the most
common performance questions
we get with respect to
Google Cloud Storage
is related to what
type of buckets
should I use for the
best performance, which
is a really good question.
When you create
a new GCS bucket,
one of the first
things you need to do
is decide what type of
storage class it has.
And while the text
there is descriptive,
there's not a lot of room to
discuss all the performance
nuances.
Generally, these classes can
be broken into two categories.
Nearline and Codeline
are built for content
which is accessed
infrequently, and thus, latency
shouldn't really be considered
when fetching from them.
Regional and
multi-regional, however,
are expected to serve
data as fast as possible.
So what do those terms
actually mean, though?
Well, a regional GCS
bucket guarantees
that all the data
in that bucket lies
in a specified region,
which you determine
when you create the bucket.
This type of location is
really important in situations
where you know your client are
or on-prem systems are located
and you want to get your GCS
buckets as close to those
systems as possible.
Multi-regional storage,
on the other hand,
guarantees two
replicas of your data
which are geo-diverse,
about 100 miles apart or so.
This results in the
data being moved
between regions for better
latency and availability.
More importantly is
that multi-regional
heavily leverages
edge caching and CDNs
to provide content to the end
users as fast as possible.
To understand how these
systems respond under stress,
we set up a simple test.
Upload a two megabyte
file to a bunch
of regional and
multi-regional buckets
and fetch that asset with
caching disabled from a VM
in US west one.
First, there's a
couple of things
that we can discern
from this data.
For fetches in the same
region or in a sub-region
of the multi-region,
performance is pretty on par.
However, once we
get across oceans,
we can see that the
multi-regional buckets
tend to perform better.
The reason for this
is that their data
was duplicated to a region
of the multi-region, which
provides better access
point and lower latency
to our fetching client.
What these tests show
us is that there's
no really specific
performance different
of the classifications of
the buckets themselves.
Rather, the performance
is dominated
by the latency of physics of
the distance between the clients
and the cloud storage bucket.
However, to be clear,
with caching on,
your read performance for both
regional and multi-regional
should look something like this.
So if caching is on,
Google's powerful CDN
can help improve your
read performance,
regardless of the bucket.
But if caching is
off, then it's best
to pick a class that
puts your content as
close to your
endpoints as possible.
To learn more about the perf
details of these buckets,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]